So far you've learned a lot about writing Java programs.
And in this lesson, I'll show you how to run them on your own computer.
To create and run programs,
your computer will need a few tools.
We'll be downloading and using two pieces of software.
The first is called the Java Development Kit.
The second is an application called IntelliJ.
The Java Development kit includes the basic software you'll need to
run Java programs and IntelliJ includes extra tools that will help you edit and run code.
And we'll learn more about both of these in a bit.
Let's start by taking a closer look at
the Java Development Kit and some of the software it contains.